gales le président de la république doit
maintenant engager enfin j'allais dire
les mesures pour lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
risque en politique c'est une volonté de
détruire les valeurs de la république
l'islam radical à pénétrer l'école
l'islam radical à pénétrer le milieu
associatif l'islam radical est présent
dans un certain nombre de lieux de
prières et nous avons produit 12 rapport
parlementaire pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé je le dis la république est en
danger
elle est en danger aussi de nos
renoncements nous pensons qu'il
suffirait de manifester nous rassembler
maintenant il faut agir
notre loi nous dans une démocratie dans
une société héritière des lumières c'est
la liberté de pensée et la liberté de
caricaturer la liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire dans le respect des
valeurs communes qui est des valeurs de
la république et le communautarisme
c'est une forme de pas simplement de
séparation mais c'est une forme
d'atteinte très profonde à la république
elle même et je crois que rappeler que
nul ne peut se prévaloir de son origine
dont le vol avait eu sa religion pour
l'exonérer pour s'exonérer de la règle
commune dokht à chaque fois qu'il sera
nécessaire
e pardonnez le législateur il continue à
croire la loi et la loi doit protéger la
foi tant que la fois n'entend pas dicter
la loi je crois que la laïcité ça n'est
ni un intégrisme ni du laxisme c'est
tout simplement de rappeler que la
primauté de la loi de la république
s'impose à tous